KEVIN VIK: Very
delighted to have
the writer and director of the
film "Screenagers," Dr. Delaney
Ruston.
So let's welcome her.
[APPLAUSE]
So, Delaney, tell us about
just what the film is about
and where you got
this idea from.
DELANEY RUSTON: Sure.
Well, "Screenagers"
is a film that
looks at my personal
story and the stories
of all different age groups
about the impact of all
this screen time on kids.
And really, as a physician,
I was interested in this.
But most importantly, as a mom,
with two young teenagers who
wanted more and
more screen time,
I was really figuring
out, ah, what do I do,
feeling really out of control.
And often is the case
when I feel this way,
is I start filming, and now
here we are with "Screenagers"
out for almost a year now.
And it is just creating
a huge movement,
and I'm really excited about
that and excited to be here
at Google talking about it.
KEVIN VIK: What has been the
response from parents, and even
from some kids or teenagers
that you've shown this to?
DELANEY RUSTON: Yeah, I mean
parents really want solutions.
And so I really made sure
that the film was about that.
And what I really
wanted to do is
get people talking,
because it was interesting.
I had been doing films
on mental health issues,
and I did one, for example,
on global mental health.
Trying to find people
in China and India
to talk about mental
illness is not easy.
I came back here.
Trying to find parents to talk
about struggles in their home
was so much harder,
and I realized
how private parenting is.
And so I wanted the film
to be shown in communities
and get kids, parents, teachers,
all of us talking about how are
we going to manage
this for our kids,
how are we going to
get them to manage it.
And the response has been,
that's great, I brought my kid,
we had a great talk,
we're still talking.
Educators are talking now with
their kids about these issues
more, so that's been great.
Kids really like the
science, which has been fun.
Sometimes they're defensive, and
then it's a great conversation
to have with them.
What did this bring up with you?
What are appropriate
screen time limits?
So it's been across the board
critical in making discussions
happen, and that's
really what my goal was.
KEVIN VIK: Well, it's
a phenomenal film,
and seeing it, and
seeing it's very funny--
we were laughing.
I came in a group was laughing a
few times during the screening.
I was laughing.
What was so interesting was--
I guess, what were some of
the surprises that you found?
Because I found a
lot of surprises
myself just from
listening to it.
I'm like, oh, wow, that hits
the nail right on the head.
But what were some
of the surprises
that you found that
you may not have
known before just outside
of your own child,
your own experience
with your own child,
that other parents
were experiencing?
DELANEY RUSTON:
Well, first, I have
to say when my daughter saw the
film for the first time, who's
in the film--
here I was.
I had been making it
for a couple of years,
and the first reaction
was, I didn't realize
other kids were dealing
with all these issues
around rules or not.
I'm like, Tessa, what have we--
KEVIN VIK: Like
she's the only one.
DELANEY RUSTON:
Yes, the only one.
KEVIN VIK: The only
one dealing with this.
DELANEY RUSTON: And
I think parents often
feel that way, too.
And it's particularly
interesting
that parents feel self-conscious
about talking about solutions.
You do hear parents
saying I'm struggling,
but in terms of saying
what kind of rules
they've tried and haven't
tried, you feel really judged.
And that's what I
really wanted to say.
We've got to get out there.
We've got to be
talking about how
do we decide when tech should
be put away and in what spaces.
And that's not
necessarily easy to do
when it is so dopamine-rich.
And to answer your
question, in terms
of surprises that I found
looking at the science,
was first and
foremost that there
is no other age in our
life than our teenage years
when our pleasure
center is physically
the biggest, that you have
the most dopamine there
at any time.
So it wasn't that it
was our first-time kiss
that it was so great.
It was actually that we were
pumping dopamine at that time.
And so what the
kids' experiences
are and their vulnerability to
that intense dopamine rushes
from some of the most
fascinating video games
and all sorts of things--
that's what we really
have to be aware of
and be responsible about
stepping up to the challenge
that we can create
balance around this.
KEVIN VIK: How did you
deal with your daughter
when you look at--
I mean, you came up
with this contract.
I thought it was really funny,
where you made basically
this four- or five-page
contract for her.
And so but what is that
balance when you have--
because it was interesting.
What you asked your daughter
was, why do you want a phone?
Convince me why you need
this smartphone, why you
need this iPhone or whatever.
And she-- all my friends
have it and everyone has it.
So I mean, as a parent,
how do you say no to a kid
when everyone else is doing it?
Because at that age it doesn't
matter what their parents say.
It just matters everyone
else is doing it,
so I should be able to do it.
DELANEY RUSTON: Yeah.
You know, it's interesting.
One of the movements that
we've started with the film
is called Tech Talk
Tuesday, and it's exactly
about having these kinds
of conversations that
are easy to not have to do.
Because you're just busy and
you just have a reactive answer.
Well, I don't care
what everyone's doing.
So Tech Talk Tuesday,
every week we
give discussion prompts
as part of the solution,
how to have these conversations.
And actually, today's
Tech Talk Tuesday
on the "Screenagers"
movie website
is exactly that
question of what age
is appropriate to get a kid a
mobile device, a smartphone.
And there's a lot of
discussion about it.
What I've seen over
making this film is,
of course, kids at
younger and younger ages
are getting smartphones.
One recent survey,
7% of four-year-olds
own their own smartphone.
75% of four-year-olds own
their own mobile device.
A lot of those are
some sort of an iPad.
So if we don't stop and have
these discussions about what
do we do, there's a big trend
that we all see happening.
And I don't know if
we're always going
to get this right, when your
kid asks this and asks that
and you're kind of coming
up with what you feel.
I think there's two things.
I think we have a lot more
data now in the past 10 years,
so we need to be data-driven.
Definitely, this is emotional,
so it's emotionally fueled.
It's our kids.
But it should be data-driven.
And I think that when
we do that, we're
going to parent with
integrity, and that's
what we'll look back
and feel good about,
rather than, it's too
late, nothing I can do.
It's actually not too late.
If you have a teenager and they
have devices in their bedroom
and you look at the study
that shows much more
convincingly how poor sleep
affects emotional development,
academic development,
you might say,
hey, I know you've
been pretty good,
you've had your
phone there, I know
you put it on the other side
of the room where it's silent.
But I'm just going
to feel better.
Because self-control
goes down when
we're tired, all these things.
Let's talk about
the science, but I
think we need to all have our
devices out of the bedroom.
That's an example of having
these kind of conversations,
doing them calmly,
weekly, Tech Talk Tuesday.
And kids actually
really respect that.
You're modeling to
them that you're going
to do this with integrity.
And they might be
frustrated in the beginning,
but actually they'll
feel the difference
and they'll be happy
that you did that.
KEVIN VIK: Is your son getting
off a little bit easier
than your daughter?
Because she's kind of taking
the brunt of it, right?
Because she was 13, I guess,
when you do this whole contract
thing, right?
DELANEY RUSTON: It's
interesting that you say that.
My son's a senior
now in high school,
and I really was kind of
thinking this issue of, oh,
he's an older teenager,
what can I do now?
And I notice he just was,
when we were in the kitchen,
kind of as he was moving around,
just a lot more on his phone.
And it just snuck up on us.
And I said, what's
going on; it seems
like you're really always on.
And he said, wow, you
know, you're right.
And he went off his
phone for a week
just to kind of
see how that felt.
There was some
frustrating times where
he couldn't get
directions or some things
and we had to talk
about, OK, how are you
going to preempt that.
And he said it's
helped him to reset.
So it was a good reminder
to me that all of us
need sometimes just a little
poke and a little thing.
And it's ultimately
the goal, though,
is really to get our kids
to have that mindfulness
that they can
experiment with this.
Because it truly is just a
daily experiment about how do
we live to our fullest
when we have lots of things
that we want to do
online and offline.
KEVIN VIK: So I'm going to open
it up to audience questions.
SPEAKER 1: So one thing
I've heard about anecdotally
is teenagers having a lot
more ergonomic problems,
like in their wrists and
neck, than they used to.
I was curious if
you ran across any
of that in your investigations.
DELANEY RUSTON: Yeah,
I mean, absolutely.
Posture and other
thumb tendonitis
things are happening more.
Also near-sightedness
is a discussion.
We don't have a definitive,
but absolutely anybody
can be prone and get.
It's not how much increased
risk that is per person.
It's hard to say
because there's so
many genetic and other
factors going in.
But with the different
game devices,
in particular,
you have some kids
who are playing games six
hours a day, and some of them
are prone to having
pain in those regions.
SPEAKER 2: Obviously, the
movie focused on teenagers,
but I'm wondering.
Younger kids are just
as much into technology
and they don't have the
ability to be rational
and to understand
data-driven explanation.
So what advice do you
have on younger kids?
I have a four-year-old nephew
who had a temper tantrum
when the iPad was taken away.
So what can we as parents
do to deal with the younger
kids and technology?
DELANEY RUSTON: I think
there's a lot of discussion
about how we set parameters
and have kids' involvement.
And I think even at a young
age, that is reasonable
and a great approach.
And so even in that
setting, would it
be more helpful if I gave you 10
minutes or five-minute warning
before your screen time is over?
And that will go a long
way in letting them
feel like they're involved.
But absolutely.
They might cry and say, no
rule will ever work here.
And it's a question of
doing that kind of work now
versus paying a lot more later.
And I'll give you an example.
The same study I mentioned
earlier with young kids--
it turns out that
25% of those parents
are using devices for
kids to go to bed with.
And over half of them
are using devices
when they are shopping or
want to get things done--
particularly also, obviously,
when a kid is upset.
So one concern is that,
are we training them
when they're
uncomfortable, when they're
upset to go to a
screen as opposed
to self-soothe, talk to a
friend, exercise, other things.
We're really giving
that dopamine quick--
screen right away.
And what I mean by pay
later is that as they
get stronger and
bigger, and if they're
really prone to
this affinity, it
can be a lot bigger
struggles later on.
So we do have a lot on
ScreenagersMovie.com
about addressing
the different ages.
And I'd say I'm
just so fascinated
as a physician, and all of
us as individuals here, we
know that certain people
have strong reactions
to pleasurable stimuli.
It's just a known thing.
I do not like white wine at
all, but I know a lot of you
must really like wine.
I love sugar to the--
I can't even put words.
My husband, sugar-- could
totally live without it.
And there's the
same thing going on
for a lot of people
with screens,
with video games, whatever
the different things they're
prone to.
And as a parent,
I would just say
to have a real wake-up
call in terms of if there's
a pattern where they're having
really extreme withdrawal
feelings and fighting and
aggression on screen time being
turned off, it's a
good time to say, OK,
I need to get really
mindful about this
and how are we going
to manage this.
I need to read about this.
I need to talk to others.
And it's going to go a long way.
KEVIN VIK: We see
that in the film
with the single mother
who had the child.
She was a single--
DELANEY RUSTON: Grandmother.
KEVIN VIK:
--grandmother, right, who
had a kid who she's just like,
he just likes his video games.
But take them away,
he punches the wall,
kicks the wall, stuff like that.
And he's just like, no.
And it's interesting
kind of seeing--
DELANEY RUSTON: And one of my
favorite parts in the movie
is when she goes to see
that super cool social
worker/counselor.
Because, again,
as a physician, I
work with a ton of counselors.
Because the way that we
reframe and the outside help
is so critical that I really
wanted to put that in there.
I think we really
need a movement.
Lisa, my co-producer,
is here with me today.
I'm so happy about that.
We're talking about today,
we really need a crisis line
and restart where you saw that
deals with kids who really do
have addiction issues
around screen time.
They get flooded with calls.
But it doesn't even have
to be that high a level.
But I have people
now call me a lot,
and I do kind of impromptu
ongoing counseling for them,
brainstorming and helping them
to get new ways of thinking
and approaching this.
Because it's intense.
30% of families
in America report
that they are struggling
daily about screen
time with their kids.
It's sad, but it's
also an opportunity.
It's like if we can use this
opportunity of how we're
going to have resolution
of conflicts, that's
going to go a long way to
teach them in their work,
in their relationships.
It's the number one thing that
predicts for relationships,
is not how many cool
things you guys do together
or mountain biking in Marin,
but how you resolve conflicts.
And so learning
how to do that with
small, frequent conversations
with really pinning yourself
down.
What are a few
times that we don't
think that tech should be used
so that our relationships can
be stronger?
Why is it that 70%
of parents allow
kids to use devices
in the car when that
can be really valuable time?
Like, let's wake up and
say, sorry, it's not safe,
it's not great,
let's listen to music
together, let's be together.
There are these
kind of discussions
we're having about rethinking
how we're going to create
these cherished moments.
KEVIN VIK: It's
interesting, too,
because seeing the kids being
so attached to their screens
and go right to the
video game and try to be
immersed in these worlds--
I just think when I was
a kid, when we were kids,
we would go play in
the forest and we
would have to pretend like
we were the Ninja Turtles
or we were the Power
Rangers or whatever.
And how would you suggest
a parent going after that
or going about that
with their child,
saying, there is a world out
there, just in your head?
And you can actually
pretend and play out
there versus just having
to immerse yourself
into World of Warcraft or
Minecraft or whatever it is.
DELANEY RUSTON:
Well, I think that it
gets to a bigger question of why
do we care that kids not just
be on screens all the time.
And as a parent, I think
that's really important
that we think about where our
kids are at-- or as a mentor
or teacher-- and where we
want to make sure that they
get to offline experiences.
And I break it down
into three main things.
Creativity, communication,
and competency.
And what's really
interesting about what you're
saying about creativity,
like create with your mind
and be out there
in the world, is
it turns out when they survey
what kids are doing on screens,
only 3% of the time
is content creation.
It's pretty amazing when
you can make videos,
you can make music,
you can write blogs.
And frankly, the reason
is to create and to work
is much harder than
to play and to watch,
and so our brain
often will default,
even though doing that
work, you actually
feel better after, the longer.
You gain self-confidence
from what we do.
So I think that
if your kid is not
spending a fair
amount of time doing
mental creation or
other creation as one
of those things--
creation, communication,
and competency--
I think that's a great
starting point to say, hey,
I want to make sure you're also
creating offline and having
time to think with your
brain and write it down.
And also, let's re-look at
what you're doing online.
You're in this game;
that's fabulous.
Hey, there's this program by
which you can develop a game.
So I think having that mindset
can really be effective.
SPEAKER 3: So first of
all, thank you very much.
That was really
amazing and, I guess,
probably a wake-up
call for many people.
So I have two questions.
First question-- since you also
touched on the digital identity
part and how we lead
and how we help kids,
personally I found
it really brave
that you put your family, your
own family, in that movie.
And I would like to discuss
what was the process of deciding
how many of those scenes
and how much of your family
you should expose to the world.
And I assume this movie goes
really, really well, which
I really hope and wish.
Your kids will probably become
celebrities through this movie.
So how do you weigh this
thing of doing something
for the world that
is really meaningful
versus introducing risks
to your own family?
DELANEY RUSTON:
Well, I have to say,
I wasn't at all intending to
put my family into this film.
I thought it was just looking
at video games and social media,
and I didn't think
it called for that.
But it actually was,
because it was hard for me
to find families who would
let me in in real time.
Again, I think that we totally
crave true, real moments.
And even reality TV is.
So now we see it.
It's so doctored.
So ultimately, my kids have been
used to my filming in the home
for so long, and we didn't know
what the film would become.
They didn't know.
Fortunately, since
mainly it's my daughter,
she has been OK and
happy with the film,
and she does a lot
of the Q&As with me.
She has moments
when she sees parts
in there where she's like, oh.
And recently, this
last week, I tried
to film her on some emotional
stuff that's happening.
And she's 15 and
she said, I don't
know, I don't know if I
want to be filmed now, Mom.
It's great about "Screenagers."
I'm just not sure.
So it'll be interesting to see.
I think it would be great
if everyone did this.
Have your kids
film you about what
do you think you're struggling
with, with balance and screen
time, and film them.
I mean, we use it
a lot in medicine
to see how we communicate
as physicians.
We film the medical students
and then we evaluate that.
And everyone can be creating
and have that self-reflection.
Again, anything that
we can do to make
our kids more mindful, more
curious about all of this,
as opposed to just
immediately pulled in, we're
doing half our battle.
We really are.
SPEAKER 3: How can we make
the most out of this treasure?
And what I mean
is, first of all,
I would hope that
it will not become
like a compulsory screening,
but at least this movement
will go far away--
I don't know--
like 60%, 70%, 90%
of teenagers, students
in the US will
be able to watch it
with their parents.
Hopefully, perhaps, legislators
also will have a chance.
I don't know if you
can have a screening
at the Congress or something.
If you could talk
a little bit more,
how we could take this movement
and move it along and also.
And also, one more follow-up--
if you could have a
follow-up to that movement
to see how actually
having seen the movie
has affected the families
and the digital awareness.
DELANEY RUSTON: So to answer
your first question about how
to build this
movement, how do we
get all families and kids to
see this movie-- because it's
one hour of their life.
And yet screen time is
somewhere around seven hours
a day for kids and adults,
not including school work
and not including work.
So with this one hour
to get us to think,
what do we agree with,
what we don't, what
is the science, what
science do we need--
we are all for it.
We have now almost
2,000 screenings
that have been booked
around the country
and in about 20
different countries.
And we're working with many
different companies who've
brought it--
Pixar and LucasFilms and a lot
of tech companies and all over.
But we really believe that it is
about bringing people together.
And so at
ScreenagersMovie.com, anyone
can bring it to their church,
to their after-school activity
program.
So I think that
all of you help us
in getting the word out to
bring it to schools and whatnot.
And the other thing that
everyone can do today
is that Tech Talk Tuesday--
next week will be our
50th week of doing it.
If you take a pledge to do
one of them on our website,
it's basically saying
to your kids, hey,
I want to take a pledge
to not be reactive.
I.e., what I always do is
I do the grab-and-stab.
I grab my daughter's
phone and then I
kind of stare at her
in the eyes, like, ugh,
I told you not to be on it then.
And through doing these
Tech Talk Tuesdays, calm
conversations, I really become
less reactive and more curious
and am able to deal with that.
So I hope people will do the
Tech Talk Tuesday pledge.
In terms of a follow-up
movie, just a couple of weeks
ago the "Today Show"
had a group of teenagers
that they showed the
film to, and then they
had them give up their phone
and technology for a week.
And they saw what happened.
So it's on our website
and it's fun to watch.
So we'll see what the next
full feature film will be.
SPEAKER 4: So this is
really funny timing
in terms of the screening,
because actually I'm
a very recent teenager myself.
And also, for the
past month, I've
given up social media, just
to basically disconnect, what
was mentioned in the movie.
We are hooked and
addicted, but a lot of us
have a yearning to not be and
to not be controlled by what
we feel like is very addicting.
So I just want to say, first of
all, this is such a great film
and really touched upon a lot
of very relatable experiences.
Already, being off
social media, I'm
so much more productive at work.
I'm actually doing things
that I enjoy outside
of just mindlessly scrolling.
I don't know if you've thought
about this or have the answer,
but something I'm
just thinking about
is the condition of the screens.
So obviously, if we have
screens, it's very distracting.
It's something we can look at.
And wherever you go,
the cafe, the bus,
everywhere, everyone is just
looking down at their screens.
But more and more people now are
saying that the future of tech
is very quickly
becoming screen-less--
like Google Home, Alexa,
all those things, the watch.
Or I guess the watch
is still a screen,
but you get what I mean.
So do you think that the problem
lies in the screen itself,
or is there something
just about technology
that is the real challenge?
DELANEY RUSTON: I think
you've really hit on something
that is key, is what you
did is you replaced it.
And as a physician that works in
primary care, half of what I do
is behavior change.
And it's not, OK, you got
to stop smoking cigarettes.
It's, what are we going to
do in place of that urge
when you have it.
It never works to replace
with a vacuum, so fantastic
that you are doing other things
that you're excited about.
I would say that the
other thing that I'm
excited that you're talking
about is that you're modeling.
You are here in
the cafe and you're
probably having a
better conversation,
or you're just breathing.
I know you do a
lot of mindfulness.
You're taking that moment to
kind of refresh your brain,
and that modeling is key.
I just learned
that 80% of parents
think they actually
are good models.
If you are highly educated, you
are more likely to think that.
And I think it's in
part because we justify.
I have to do it for work, and
kids, well, it's different.
We need to figure
out how to model
in terms of change
one behavior--
like, you know what,
I'm going to work.
I'm going to say to
my kids, I really
am checking too
much during dinner.
And I'm going to say to them,
I'm going to work on this.
Guys, help me.
Because to change
behavior, it takes
a lot of different issues.
Again, on the
"Screenagers" movie site,
I spent a lot of time on that.
Because you made it seem easy,
but it's often not so easy.
Your real question, though,
is in terms of screen time,
is it the screen, what is it--
I think a big thing
that we have to know
is that our brain does
not like to be bored.
And I don't know if you just
saw the study that came out
in "Science Magazine,"
when they put people
into a room with nothing
to do for 15 minutes.
Over a quarter of them
chose to give themselves
an electric shock rather
than just sit there, even
though prior they had paid
experimental money to not be
shocked.
They didn't like the shock.
It was just being
bored and sitting
there was nerve-wracking.
And when we give kids now
these devices in the car.
The car.
There's so much cool
things driving by.
If that's not cool to be
thinking and daydreaming,
have the music, whatever,
we're really setting them up
to be more uncomfortable
having those moments
where there's boredom,
and then our brain ideally
will find new ideas to go to.
Because "Bored and Brilliant"--
there's a whole concept
that a lot of creativity
comes from those moments.
But in the moment,
in the immediacy,
we get scared of those moments.
KEVIN VIK: Well, thank
you so much for being
here, Dr. Delaney Ruston.
[APPLAUSE]